[Music]
hands down
best jackie chan movie of all time yeah
drunken drunk
drunken fighter
you don't even know the name in the
movie i was zero years old when i came
out
true you're not allowed to talk about
someone else rumble in the bronx only
because it was my first
one and it was like the actually
released here in the state yeah yeah
yeah yeah true
what about oh i probably saw it when i
was a kid but i didn't know
that was jackie chan oh he's like that
dude's tight became jack
yeah in rumble in the bronx that's true
yeah bart i
can't name just one just do one
anything okay don't even rank it uh
rumble on the bronx rugged master ii
rush hour that movie have you seen that
one which rush are
rush hour two this was a drunken master
of the shower
that drunken fighter one title the
second drunken master
second drunken master oh yeah because
the real original drunken master was
like in the 70s
they went like 20 years it's kind of
it's kind of rough around the edges a
little bit yeah it's a little janky
looking yeah it doesn't have that flare
and like that
compelling story and there was two of
them yeah the second one
which was the one that he's running on
the cars and then the guys on the bike
oh that's the second one
cute can you can you ride your bike
again
he's going to go see that girl michael
going through a mall
and crashing through glass and [ __ ] no
no is that rubble in the bronx
oh yeah on the cards oh that's rubble in
the bronx yeah i'm in the mall though
you just saw that girl or something he's
wearing the white did he drink gasoline
yes or no and then became a superhero
because there's one he drink gasoline
and then the the guy
the most arch nemesis guy he has his
crazy legs
the jackie chan he's like this and then
he turns into like this guy
could learn anything [ __ ] and
then so he starts going
oh that's yeah the drunken master yeah
and then that hit the nemesis is like
what the [ __ ] and he just keeps drinking
this gasoline he learned my style
and what's cool a fun fact is that guy
is actually jackie chan's bodyguard in
real life
so he brought his bodyguard into the
movie with them which i thought was sick
that's funny how jackie chan needs a
bodyguard what about you guys do you
guys have a favorite jackie chan movie
i don't know i'm like i think this
question's falling on deaf ears here but
no i mean i really i off the top of my
head and the the clearest
memory of a movie of with jackie chan in
it that i liked was rush hour but it's
just so
such a basic answer i don't know because
that's all it's all the ones we if
that's the one that we all
know because the first one is the one
that i've seen many many
so that's the one that's really fresh in
my brain so i would say the first one
i don't want trouble have you guys
watched it recently
a lot of the jokes will not fly today
really
like one of them was like i could just
just because of how sensitive people are
where's one where she's uh i think rush
hour two
where they're going back to the car they
just saw isabella when she was like
changing
and then um chris tucker was pretty much
saying like oh like
you see the way he was looking at me um
i'm tall dark and handsome or whatever
and then jackie chan is like oh no no no
you should see the way she was looking
at me and then
chris turner was like what you're third
world ugly and then i'm like
i don't know if you could say that these
are true but i was dying in the living
third world
ugly the the i'll slap you back to
africa
yeah i'll [ __ ] slap you back to africa
yeah it's not frank lies
is fry lies you preach
that what's that from is that isn't that
rush hour yeah rush hour because then
there's another movie that
oh it's with jet li it's a [ __ ] uh
lethal weapon four
there's a lot of like those kinds of
jokes too but rush hour one rush hour
two
[ __ ] they're so so good so dope yeah
wait what's the jet li one when
it's the casino with the with the with
the leah wait is it aliyah yeah
yeah was it that yeah that one probably
we tried watching that recently
i like that movie still too that was
such a weird
kiss scene it's [ __ ] weird i think
aaliyah at the time was still
pretty young and then jet li just looks
like an old man to me like 20 years old
older than her yeah what was the the
jerry chan movie where the guy gets
thrown in the wood chipper he has to
come with a bag
and then he's on first strike yeah he's
on the big inflatable thing
wait isn't that rubble in the box or
maybe he's in the wood chipper right
like like one of the goons
like you see like the the moss bot a mob
uh what the phone might say
the mafia guy's got the moss bobby
the one where he breaks his foot and has
to wear that sock yeah yeah yeah that
one
that's rubble in the box right with the
hoverboard yeah yeah which one's the one
where jackie chan's in a getaway car
and then he like does this crazy then he
does it who am i
that one that one's sick [ __ ] sick
the rooftop fight
oh and he jumps off the roof and slides
he parks it and he goes
and then they like zumba he's made like
over 100 movies hasn't he
yeah he's broken like over 100 bones how
many bones are in the human body is
there even 186
136 he's right now forgot something
about that
but yeah the reason why we're talking
about jackie chan though it's so good
oh that took a minute i know right i was
like oh i love jackie chan so i'm just
kind of like
let's just talk about his movie i love
you jackie [ __ ] kiss you
yeah would you i would love to be i
would love to work with them like that's
that's like a big dream
how does a pain in the ass work with him
oh it's so big yeah of course let's ask
our friends they worked with them true
oh true martial club get the skinny on
that
but yeah so we're talking about jackie
chan and uh
recently next shark uh posted an article
talking about jackie chan's dad and mom
and this is apparently old news and
nadeem you already knew this
but like it was news to me joe you're
like jackie chan fans and we
had no idea no idea and so
the the crazy part about all this is
that when jackie chan was already
like a grown ass adult and i think he
was already starting his career
he found out that his dad
was a uh government spy
oh he didn't even know himself he didn't
know jackie chan did not know and he
found out as an
adult that his dad was a nationalist spy
working for china
against the communist party that's when
he made the movie who am i
who am i because i don't even know my
dad
i am triple 8.
give me the soju yeah
and then check this how did jackie
chan's dad who is
his name is charles chan how did he meet
the mom
by arresting her when she was
she's a drugged she was an opium
smuggler
crazy and also a a big sister a diet set
which means like she's you know she's
getting my boss
qualities and when her inner circle
that's like a female dylo emotional yeah
dailo yep
yeah you have to be a pretty badass to
get a girl like that that's true that's
a lady manager of the drug trade
lady and apparently she was also like a
really uh
gangster as uh gambler too like she she
gambled a lot and
and you're living through gambling and
drug dealing that's exciting yeah
and to not know that about your parents
it's all time it's my kids
that's what i tell you who am i who am i
but yeah so then he found out all this
[ __ ] and then and then the craziest part
too is that they all changed their last
names so jackie chan
could have possibly been jackie fang i
like chad
better and jackie fang that's actually
pretty cool i don't like it
made it very far but i mean it already
sounds like like a friend
like a popular name you know like or
just like it could have been like a
superstar name
um it sounds better jackie chan
i mean it sounds good because we know it
yeah
imagine a different dimension we're
having this exact same conversation but
reverse
it's like it only sounds right jackie
fang like
how is it ducky chan it's so weird
jackie chan so weird
so his they his dad just gave it up like
they ran away to hong kong what was the
whole so basically
his dad ran away from china uh sought
refuge first in australia
at an american embassy and he stayed
hiding there for a lot of years
and then uh i don't know with his no
lady
yet i'm not quite sure what the timeline
is but yeah somewhere in there he met
the mom
by arresting her and then somehow a
relationship flourished i wonder if they
uh
role play arresting her like again i bet
right he's like oh no
like oh that's too tight oh what's that
[Laughter]
freeze in the name of the law
what you're gonna do i'm gonna punish
you oh [ __ ]
you should do it
oh and he has two uh brother or two
siblings uh
from his mom's side that he he never
knew about whoa did he do a 23 of me and
he was like
yeah i have a sibling man
yeah i don't know if you ever like
connect for him yeah oh
i don't know if he's an only child but
just based on this article here
he has two other brothers from his mom's
side and
the father of those kids died in a uh
an air raid like a bomb like
it was a war-torn war-torn country at
the time
they didn't do a biopic on this fool
yeah they dude that would be
family that'd be sick they did one on it
man
and no one even knew where the [ __ ] he
was true would they sensationalize
jackie chan to be like this
mega fighting capable guy or do you
think they would do it like
realistically if they made it over there
since he's a baby he's been doing
backflips true
but if they do it over here it'll be
more dramatic and like true which one
would you prefer to see
the other one taking out bad guys hey
he's been kicking ass since he's five
that's what i want to see yeah i always
find out
interesting in like the chinese like
film community
like they've always liked folk heroes
and they never tell it as it is they
always they like lies i love
making a like uh johnny appleseed like
like this guy planted so many apple
trees and that's like the nation's
[ __ ] fruit and we love apple pies
that's the most american thing
i don't know if that's true but that's
the legend yeah everything starts off as
a caricature already
it's not like how accurate we can make
it it's like what's the best story to
tell yeah
did you know jackie chan can fly that's
fun
yeah that's a lot of imagination that's
true like they did that to like uh one
film
they did that to it man now and then
like i mean the reason only reason why
they haven't done bruce lee yet is
because i mean he's just so recognizable
yeah they don't look like well yeah i
don't know
yeah that that hapa or i don't know
what's the what's the chinese term for
hapa there isn't one
but i know that it man like before the
movies came out
from my understanding of it man like
what my parents told me
was i did know he was bruce lee's master
but he was just this frail guy that was
addicted to opium
so i've always had him in like a bad
light in my mind just
learning about him in kung fu school
learning about it from our parents
he's not the honorable martial artist
that you think about he's addicted to
opium he's [ __ ] frail and [ __ ]
and then bruce lee is his only star
student if he was such a good master
you'd have 10 star students
oh true but then uh when the movie came
i'm like man i've been a fan of it man
[Laughter]
was there a documentary that came out
too that or what do you mean
well they probably said that about him
because they didn't like change or like
go against the grain of like how it's
supposed to be taught yeah but
i think also just being addicted to
drugs is just but was it it's not very
what it was it's not very kung fu back
then though so ant-man
trained bruce lee yeah he trained bruce
lee and that's really his
only claim to fame if it wasn't for
maybe just out here no
or is it over there too even though i
mean he was like like
uh like a really sought after master but
i think there's a lot of those in china
especially during those times yeah so
like he was kind of just like one
out of a million right and and not one
out of a million but like he was one of
many
and um the fact that he had bruce lee as
a student that
propelled his legend to be like movie
but bruce lee's like
you i mean he learned from chuck norris
he learned from
muhammad ali like his style that and
then the nunchucks from
uh [ __ ] fumio demura like all of his
stuff
his fighting style now isn't it man's
teachings true the coolest
bruce lee stuff was not from mit man no
the kicks and all those things are just
it's from karate or it's from you know
something else boxing
yeah let's let's take away a man's
legacy yeah take it away because i'm
like
what did it really teach them you know i
don't know
it's really it's really just bruce lee
in his brain
i think it's bruce lee to pull things
from what he wants
and create his own [ __ ] it's really
i think that's what i'm saying is people
are glorifying it man more than bruce
lee and i'm just like bruce lee's
probably the guy that made himself
true true do you have photos of their
pens
oh yeah i do you want to see
the parents what's mr triple eight look
like
like exactly how he looks right now in
real life i feel like that is
kind of jackie chan dad that's the
jackie chan mom
oh i want to see them younger yeah don't
you have the black and white one the
black and white one no
damn dude his mom just she looks like
she could cook some mean food
she's a [ __ ] drug dealer type in
jackie chan's parents you'll get the
the original photo that went viral oh he
looks cool he looks like
[ __ ] though he looks just like his dad
he looks hard as [ __ ] he looks like a
boss
how did you find out uh i don't know i
think they were shooting a documentary
based on this article it seems like
they're shooting a documentary so then
they were already kind of in a place of
just
finding out more about him and he asked
his own parents like more information
about their background and
that's what came to light do you think
back then
a smuggler didn't have the same weight
and like negativity the way that we
think of smugglers
i think they did because wasn't society
more uptight
about drugs yeah it might be worse back
you know back then even making alcohol
like oh you're a moonshiner it's almost
like you're dealing cocaine
but now you look at alcohol like ah
that's triple h we get it we get it
we get it hello guys thank you guys so
much for watching all of our videos and
i know it's been a million years
in the making but we finally got just
kidding news
merch yep so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
you